President Trump may use emergency powers
to stop a caravan of migrants from
crossing the US border thousands of
people from Central America are still
more than a thousand miles away in
southern Mexico the president wants to
deny them any opportunity to seek asylum
here which is Jiang is that the White
House was more on that story we good
morning good morning Gail president
Trump has repeatedly expressed his
frustration over the caravan and now the
administration is considering a wide
range of administrative legal and
legislative action the president tweeted
out a message to the migrants on
Thursday go back to your country and if
you want to apply for citizenship like
millions of others are doing Secretary
of Defense James Madison expected to
sign in order to send hundreds of
active-duty troops to the border now
those troops will join the roughly 2000
National Guardsmen the president already
sent there in April the new troops can
build barriers and help look for people
trying to cross the border illegally but
they do not have the authority to
apprehend illegal immigrants they also
won't be authorized to use force except
in self-defense our President Trump has
turned immigration into a key campaign
issues heading into the midterms and
critics say he's only doing these
potential moves to stop the caravan for
political gain given the timing now just
11 days from Election Day
bianna yeah we do they're already
threats that this could turn into a
legal battle as well thank you so much